we have to stop idolizing and emulating
the west
the west doubled down on finite they
made a lot of money
and so because they're rich we look to
them and say well they must know what
they're doing
look how rich they got look how big
their companies got
but what we're also missing is that the
average lifespan of a of an american
company in the 1950s was 60 years
the average lifespan of an american
company today is 17 years
right it's it's not working
and so please i beg you stop copying the
west
because we have our heads up our ass
right
so going back to the the sports team
versus the family
both are wrong right sports team
assumes it's a finite game where
performance is everything
because of that win win win win win and
what are we going to do to win
so that's not very helpful but it's not
really a family either
because at the end of the day if you
have a family member
who's an energy suck you
yeah you just put up with that
uncle right where in a company if
somebody's
really dragging the team down
we want them to be happy we want them to
do well but we want them to do well
somewhere else
and we've tried coaching them and
they're proved to be uncoachable
and so when we let them go trust goes up
because everybody says what took you so
long and sometimes they might be
the to my favorite ones or when
somebody's a high performer
of low trust who we know
that they're dragging down everybody
hates working with them but we we say
but their performance is so good but
finally when they when we finally muster
up the courage to ask them to leave
everybody else's performance rises and
everybody trusts us more because we
operated by our values
and so i don't like the term sports team
uh we're not we're not a sports team but
we're not a family we're a trusting team
it's it's because it's not one or the
other it has qualities
of a family and it has qualities
of a team but in an infinite sense
and so i think i like i like creating
new words for the things that we
actually are building we'll be
we're building trusting teams
um but to say we're like a family
um some of our family members would
would never operate this way and we have
no recourse but so it's it's not
they're not it's not an apples to apples
it's not a fair comparison
but i i but the i think the east and
asia
have a huge advantage over the west
which is inherently in your culture
you are just more comfortable with the
infinite concept you are more
comfortable with the idea of
the long game first of all your the
histories
of the histories of your culture
are are going back much further even if
your countries are young
your cultures are old our ours is young
our culture and our country is young
china has a thousand year plan you're
comfortable with the idea
also of the unknown and of faith
and of preparing for things and
operating with values
and honor the word honor still matters
in the east in the west we have no
concept of honor
you know if you look at some of the some
of the it's just to go down a completely
you know
funny path if you look at some of the
uh violence that exists
away from the west take arab
arabs and israeli conflict let's go for
the big one right
um one of them will
exact revenge on the other and they'll
say because you humiliated us
in the west we don't even understand
that we don't even hear the word
human like that doesn't mean anything to
us but the idea of honor
and face and humiliation these things
are real things
outside of the west and so i think
you're actually
way better equipped believe it or not to
play the infinite game
with very little new learning if you
embrace
your own histories and your own cultures
and please stop emulating the west